all right peanutty peanutty to pimp
peanutty uh where are you from i'm
originally from chicago man
you know what i'm saying yeah the south
side of chicago chicago what uh where'd
you
see grew up there well i grew up there i
was born and raised in chicago on the
south side and then i came up uh
i came out here to uh los angeles when i
was 12. okay well
tell me about your family both parents i
did but that was the reason i came to
los angeles because my father
moved to los angeles uh
the year i was born you understand so he
had been out here and i had
lived in chicago so i used to visit back
and forth about when i was five years
old my story was kind of like the boys
in the hood story where he went to live
with his dad and [ __ ] like that so
i was [ __ ] up in chicago mom couldn't
really handle it so she moved me
to los angeles you know what i mean when
i was about 12. and how would you
describe your childhood
i thought my childhood was pretty cool
you know what i'm saying i mean you know
i was broke like everybody else my mom
was a beautician
you know what i mean she did hair out
the kitchen you know what i mean but uh
with per chicago the south side i was on
the south side of chicago you know what
i mean uh
not like the west side of the bishop
well not on the west side i've you know
been out there and stuff like that a
little more rougher out there but they
got
some rougher areas out that way you know
what i mean but uh
the south side was it was cool you know
what i mean my mom
raised me right i was only child to my
mother you know what i mean so she
raised me right and uh was real keen on
education
my mom was real keen on education didn't
like me to play with guns you know
instead like if i had a gun even a water
gun or something she'd take it and
replace it with a book
you know what i mean that's type of mom
i had so you know what i mean uh
she did what she had to do it was times
i came home and the lights was off and
the heat might have been off or stuff
like that but we made the best out of it
you know what i mean i had a but
i also grew up being that my mom was a
beautician when she did work in beauty
salons
i worked around a lot of women my mom
would call me down there to sweep up
i was the one to sweep up the hair and
stuff like that but that also put me
around
a lot of women you know at a young age i
started studying women and learning
women and
being around women and i think that had
a lot to do with who i became later on
in life
no pimps in the family or anything like
that
and you know everybody thinks they're
pimping some kind of way you know what i
mean everybody thinks they got a little
bit of paper so i have some cousins
and stuff like that that might have got
a little money out of a female here and
there
might have thought there was some
pimping but it was it was a few pimps in
my
area you know what i mean that uh that
caught my attention you know what i mean
anybody show you the
ropes no no i didn't get that till way
later on in life i didn't get the game
until later on in life you know what i
mean i tried
to figure it out when i was about 15.
i tried to figure it out uh because i
had a girl but she was
she was she was a dope thing actually
but uh
she was bringing me money she kept
bringing me money and that's when it
clicked in my head like man maybe i can
maybe i can do something here but i
didn't have it figured out
i didn't know exactly what i was
supposed to do and then i had a
girlfriend
that had a gang of trick appeal you know
what i mean she had just
tremendous trick appeal and then she had
a friend who was living with her
and we was all at the motel 6. i was
about 16 by this time and we was all at
the motel six
and i kept telling them and i could show
you all how to get a lot of money i
could show but i didn't know what the
[ __ ] i was talking about
i didn't know what to tell them because
they kept saying to me like
well what tell us how can we get the
money and i was like don't even worry
about it i'm gonna
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna give you
the game i'm gonna get again i had no
game to give them i didn't know what the
[ __ ] to tell them you know what i mean
and um what ended up happening was i
came to los
angeles and i went to school out here i
went to west chester high school culver
city high school stuff like that
and i ended up going to jail and when i
went to
jail i started reading all the books i
started reading all the books that i'm
sure every pimp around the country has
read or wants to read or knows about i
started reading all the donald going
books and the iceberg schlemm books who
was one of my
mentors iceberg slim and uh
i figured it out and when i came home
from jail i didn't want to be nothing
but a full-fledged pimp
and when i was i was about 20 years old
when i when i first had my first hole
they put me in a halfway house
they put me in a halfway house right
here on crenshaw and west boulevard it
was called help is on the way
and um when i got there it was a bunch
of [ __ ] there was a co-ed
it was a co-ed facility and when i got
there i was trying to pick through the
[ __ ] you know what i mean like which
[ __ ] i like you know when i was fresh
out of jail i had muscles i was young
hung handsome holding hoes for ransom
and i was ready you know what i mean and
i was looking and none of the [ __ ]
was really
you know what i mean what i was looking
for you know what i mean it was a dude
in there
i said man there's all the [ __ ] you
got in here it was about eight or nine
[ __ ] you know
and he said well it's one more he said
but you probably ain't gonna like her he
said she's a little short fat [ __ ] i
said well where's she at
he said she's not here she's never here
bro i think they're gonna kick her out
soon because she's always leaving
and stuff like that well she [ __ ]
around and popped up
and she was a hoe and that's why she
hadn't been there because she had been
leaving going
you know selling [ __ ] being in the
streets or whatever and when she came
home she recognized me at this time i
had
fingernails and i had a finger wave and
you could just look at me and tell i was
some pimping you know
and uh me and her and ended up
compensating and we got tight
and uh i showed the [ __ ] my photo album
and [ __ ] little [ __ ] photo i might
have put together
right and um i asked her to do my hair
and she brought me in the females
cottage and i wasn't supposed to be in
the females cottage you know what i mean
and it was just me and her and she was
in there doing my hair
and she had a big ass tattoo on her neck
right she had a big tattoo on her neck
and it said some [ __ ] that i couldn't
understand especially you know when you
tattoo [ __ ] in cursive you can't really
understand
what it says but while she's leaning
over me because she's right here leaning
over me doing my hair
so when she leans over me i say well
what does that say on your neck
it had a bag of money and a money sign
and some more [ __ ] but i couldn't read
the cursive
and she said oh that was my ex's name
and i said well what does it say because
i can't read it she said it says mr
mister
i said mr mister now you gotta
understand at this time i'm on fire for
the pimping i mean everything pimping is
just
i'm into it right so i know that name
and i said mr mister
i said i only know one mr mister i said
and only mr miss i know he didn't have
no girlfriends
and she said no i wasn't his girlfriend
i said so we talking about
the mr mister from hollywood the
briefcase mr mitchell rolls royce mr man
she said yeah
i said oh you some hunting i said oh
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying we got
some things to talk about
so many [ __ ] get to talking and then
well one of the people came home and was
like
look him why you got to earn this car
why you got him in this cottage he ain't
supposed to be up in here
we need to have a meeting and they had a
big old meeting and long story short
they kicked her out for having me in the
meeting
and then i got into a fight with some
guys there because i
you know i'm sitting there arguing with
them about what's going on trying to say
hey she was just doing my hair and blah
blah blah need to fight we both got
kicked out
we didn't have nowhere to go she had a
big ass bag of clothes
and uh i didn't have but a couple
clothes because i just got out of jail
and uh long story short [ __ ] we ended up
on the bus we took the bus tokens we had
we went to
sunset boulevard you know what i mean
and that was the first
blade that i worked i was 20 years old
we got out on sunset in la brea
and i was green as a pool table you know
what i mean i didn't know nothing but
you can ash on the floor yeah but i
didn't want to let her know
that i was green right because she had
just got out of prison and she had been
home now i was 20 she was 22
at the time and uh i said oh we we the
bus let us off
on hollywood we was only 2 12. they let
us off on hollywood boulevard
so when we got up there i said oh baby
maybe we could do something up here
and she said well daddy just don't um
this [ __ ] ain't been cracking since the
80s
and i felt stupid right i didn't know
where to take the [ __ ] to right i'm
like damn i don't even know where to go
but i said i can't let the [ __ ] know
that i don't know where to take her to
right
so we walked down to la brea and [ __ ] we
walked down to the bridge sunset and we
went in the bathroom
and uh she said i'm gonna go get ready
and the [ __ ] was ballheaded she had
like
she was white girl so she you know when
white people say their hair is
short it's like fuzzy she had like a
little fuzzy thing but she had a long
bang right here right
and uh she just looked a little frumpy
but when she went in the bathroom and
came
out man she was transformed she had her
makeup on
she had her earrings on she had a long
dress on with the slit down the middle
she had put on some heels that she had
in her bag it was like some wedges
but what really [ __ ] me up about it
was she put a scarf on her head
right and it was tied in a knot in the
back and she had the one bang
hanging out so it gave off the
appearance as if she had hair
but she really didn't right but she was
gorgeous but what i liked about her is
while she was in the bathroom
dressing up another white girl came in
and i was talking to her at the table
and when little kim came out and seen me
talking to the white girl she didn't
interrupt me she didn't bother me
she did nothing she looked i looked at
her and she walked right on the bread
so the [ __ ] i was talking to she was
[ __ ] she turned out to be some
[ __ ] right she was trying to tell me
how she seen
queen black tea for down the street at
the club peanuts and all that [ __ ]
so
anyway it was a gay club so anyway um
i went outside and waited on the bus
stop and i watched little kim and i
watched her and i watched her she was
over there on like martell street or
something
and i'm watching her and uh i sent her
flag a car down or a car came up to her
and i watched her walk up to the car and
said
you know this is new to me i ain't never
did it i didn't read about it heard
about it talked about it but this is the
first time i'm doing this [ __ ]
so i see her and boom she gets in the
car
and the car drives off and i don't know
at that moment if i'm ever going to see
the [ __ ] again i got all her bags i got
all my bags
man about seven eight minutes later the
car pulled back up she got out she got
out fixing her [ __ ]
back then we had pay phones so i walked
across to the pay phone i was acting
like i was on the pay phone but i really
had no money for the goddamn pay phone i
jumped on the pay phone she walked up to
me i said how much you got
she said i got 75 i said give it to me
boom she gave me the money
i went down the street i tried to get a
room in the days in i didn't have enough
so they said go across the street i went
to this little [ __ ] room across the
street on highland
and sunset and uh
i took all our bags and carried them in
there i remember telling that story to
one of my
older pimp partners later on he said
what you was doing carrying the [ __ ]
bags pimping
you know what i'm saying you're supposed
to let the [ __ ] carry the bags
but you know i said i'm green i know
right so i'm carrying the bags and [ __ ]
and uh i take it and put it in the room
and um
she went right back out and all that
night she just kept coming in
fifties hundreds fifties hundreds she
just worked
you know and she was just so [ __ ]
trained
you know you could tell she really
represented
mr mister really really well you know
and that's what
a whole translates to other pimps and
people around the world when she comes
and she's trained and she's laced like
that
and she says oh i just came from
peanutty to pimple i was with peanut
pimp blah blah blah
you can see that she got some good
instructions and some good
game from that person because she was so
[ __ ] trained
that it was amazing i mean i remember
when we rode
up there we were on the bus and a
preacher jumped on the back of the bus
and he seen that we was in distress and
he started talking he was like yeah you
believe in god have you ever been saved
and i'm talking to him like yeah yeah
all that [ __ ] good good good
and she's looking out the window so he
looked at me says is this your girl
i said yeah yeah yeah so he says hey
young lady you know i just want to talk
to you about
you know your life and things like that
and are you okay and blah blah blah
and she just kept looking out the window
so she's ignoring them i'm embarrassed
i don't know why she's not talking to
him right
so he's steady talking to her and she's
not talking so he looks at me confused
he says hey
uh she don't talk i said uh
i i don't think she's feeling too good
right now but i don't really know why
the [ __ ] she's not talking
right well coming to find out what she's
doing is she's being in pocket
she's been a good hoe hoes don't talk to
nobody but tricks
they daddy and maybe the clerk at the
goddamn burger king
you know what i'm saying that's about it
and she went right in pocket she said
i'm trying to [ __ ] with you i'm not
going to talk to nobody
but [ __ ] if he's a preacher or who he is
i'm not talking to nobody my green ass i
didn't even know
that that's what was supposed to be
happening you know what i mean
but you know as i learned and i talked
to her and we got to talking and i
remember one time i was riding down the
street and i was so happy to have a hoe
you know what i mean i was riding down
the street with my friends and i
went and got some of my friends my
square friends and i said man i got a
hoe
i got a hoe i'm on sunset boulevard i
got a room take me back up there blah
blah blah
and they took me back and as i was going
down someone said boulevard she just
happened to be walking down the street
so now it's time for me to show off so
i'm riding in the car and i say hey look
that's the [ __ ] right there that's my
hoe
i'm crawling out the window jim jim no
no no i start off i say hey little mama
hey little mama she just keep walking so
now i'm getting a little embarrassed
with my friends cause i'm you know she's
ignoring me right so i'm like
hey baby girl you shout looking good she
keep walking
so now i'm mad so i'm like jim look him
she turned around
i said [ __ ] i know you hear me calling
you she said oh daddy i'm so sorry she
said but you know what i didn't i
you know i just got with you she said i
don't i haven't trained myself to learn
your voice yet
she said because i don't want to hear
nobody else's voice but yours
so i'm just learning your voice i heard
you calling me but i didn't know if you
was just another pimp trying to call me
or what you know what i mean but i won't
let that happen what do you think the
the basis is of that
dedication that these females will have
to their pimp because i i've heard it
many many times where they give them all
their money
they do everything they can for him
well it's vice versa because i do
everything i can for them too
you understand what i'm saying there's
so many things that are misunderstood
about this game it's a whole lot of
things misunderstood but the thing is
real pimps have long since stopped
trying to explain this to the outside
world
you understand what i'm saying because
you know i was just reading something
the other day where they said trying to
explain this game to a square
is like trying to teach a blind man
colors you understand what i'm saying
it's just not going to happen they're
never going to understand it they'll
never understand why she
does these things and comes back and
gives you all her money but even square
women i mean maybe with the exception of
oprah
you know what i mean are bad money
managers i've had women tell me that's
why i'm so confident in saying it on
your show
women have told me i can't manage money
for [ __ ] when i get money i do this
i mean square women white women all
around the united states black women are
they they're not that great with money
you have your obsessions but they're not
that great that men think different
you know what i mean so i'm an
exceptional money manager
you know what i mean i don't do drugs i
don't have habits except these [ __ ]
cigarettes
you know what i mean and um
i'm gonna take that money that you can
make way better than i can
because i can't walk down the boulevard
and catch a date
i'm just not that cute you know what i'm
saying it just don't work like that for
me i can take my shirt off i can do all
that people are not gonna stop
women can walk down the street and
actually have a man
pull up and say god damn you're gorgeous
how much what gives a girl trick appeal
as you call
i think it's a certain sexiness that
they have you know what i mean
it's a certain sexiness because she
doesn't have to be
the most beautiful woman i've taken
women and transformed them because i
understand
first of all i understand how men think
okay and i think that's a very very
key element to to knowing to be to being
in this profession
okay we are as men visual creatures
we thrive off what we see you know we
can watch a porno movie
and get aroused as where
a female can read a poem or a book and
become aroused they're more
mentally stimulated you understand so
now we know that we're catering
to the visual side of men so now what we
have to do is make her look
visually appealing to men you understand
what i'm saying so they always say why
your girls out there half naked you know
they say oh that must be one of
peanutty's [ __ ] because
she's half naked you understand what i'm
saying well i know what stops them
i know what stops the tricks i know what
makes them stop
[ __ ] we got squares and square [ __ ]
and [ __ ] right now like oh my god is her
[ __ ]
is that her [ __ ] but they're stopping
they want to talk to her you know he's
on his way to work and he see all that
ass he's like god damn wait
hold hey dude bless a u-turn you
understand what i'm saying but at the
same time back to your original question
okay so now you're making all this money
but at the end of the day you don't have
a room you don't you just went and
bought a bunch of makeup you got your
nails done you got some hills you look
beautiful
but you don't have a car you're not
getting anywhere
you're not going anywhere with this
hustle and this [ __ ] is not gonna last
forever you're not gonna be beautiful
forever
you're we're i'm not gonna be you know
what i mean we're not gonna be
good-looking people forever that pussy's
not gonna sell
forever you understand so you need to
use what you've got now
to get ahead because this is not i have
a lot of mentors in this game because
i'm very very dedicated to it bishop is
one
shantae who you need to talk to is one
uh kenny red is one these are my mentors
and like
uh like like shantae said
you know uh
this is a this game is a temporary
stepping stone to the rest of your life
this is not meant to be in this forever
i mean we're going to be
we have this in us so it's going to be a
part of us forever
but at some time at some point i can't
be spending
hours and hours up and riding down the
blade and doing
uh uh outcomes and end cars and that
[ __ ] takes a toll on you man and it's
stressful
it's stressful every time a woman goes
out to the streets
because i'm wondering is something going
to happen to her is she going to be okay
is she going to be safe
is this the night that somebody robs her
rapes her kidnaps her
so i'm always worried every time she
goes out regardless of what these other
[ __ ] try to say because you got a
million zillion [ __ ]
in this whole country that claim they
pimps and think they pimps but it might
only be maybe 20 real pimps in the whole
damn country
now i'm exaggerating but i'm but you
understand what i'm trying to say it may
only really be 20 real pimps in the
whole country
all these other [ __ ] just
talking to [ __ ] you know hey
because you got a lot of different
viewpoints about what this game is about
and and and how to play it and you got
your
you know bilbo aka
alfred golson is also another one of my
mentors
and he broke it down and he said there's
52 different types of hymns
there's the white hope hemp there's the
black hole pimp there's the
six hope hemp there's the uppercut you
got all these different types of pimps
so you're gonna hear a lot of different
theories when it comes to this game
you understand but there is only a
certain way that this [ __ ]
is supposed to be played and that way to
me
my philosophy and the philosophy that i
believe in with other real pimps
is that this is my woman like kenny red
told you
a prostitute is like your wife you
understand what i'm saying so i don't
i don't care any less for her than i
would
a woman that's not prostituted you
understand
i love her you understand i love her and
i love what she does for me now there's
people just watching this and say ah
[ __ ] you loving a whole [ __ ] that
ain't pimping i don't even want to hear
that
you understand what i'm saying because i
if i'm with my cat or my dog long enough
i'm going to develop love for it
you understand what i'm saying so how
can i not love this human
being who is going out there taking a
penitentiary chance for me
going out there taking a life chance for
me she could lose her life at any minute
she could be raped robbed she could
catch a disease health
problems and then she comes back and she
gives me all her money
and trusts me to do the right thing with
the money
meaning i'm giving you all my money
why in the [ __ ] are we still walking why
in the [ __ ] don't we have anything to
eat
why in the [ __ ] are we not living in an
apartment or a home or a house or
something
so that's trust she's trusting you to
take her money and do what needs to be
done for her and take care of her with
it
right so how could i not love that how
can i love
anything other than that so yes i love
her
you know what i mean i'm gonna love her
and hopefully she's gonna love me
to a certain degree but it's a different
type of love it's not a square's love
it's a pimp's love
it's not a square's love it's a whole's
love you understand
we have a whole different type of love
because pimps and hoes are different
creatures
we're different from the square world so
we love just like
squares love but we have a pimps and
hoes love between us
we care for each other the same way but
we care in a pimp in a whole fashion
we are we make up the pimp and whole
community
the pimping hole lifestyle you
understand if i have a baby it's going
to be with a hoe because i'm not dealing
with square [ __ ] i don't really deal
with no squid [ __ ] i don't even think
i know none
i miss square [ __ ] all the time in
the streets and i got their numbers in
my phone and i don't even [ __ ] call
them
you know because i'm my life is revolved
around pimps and hoes
that's what is the origin of tipping i
mean you think it's been around for
well they got hundreds of years or well
they got a lot of different stories
about it you know what i mean so they
talk about the bible but when they talk
about the bible they talk
about how uh uh uh
sarah and abraham and hagar and how
hagar was like a hoe
and she ran off because sarah ran her
off and she ran into the wilderness and
she started hoeing and blah blah blah
they didn't mention anything about no
pimping but at the same time
where there's a woman there are gonna be
men you know and she's gonna have a man
somewhere now if she's getting an income
whether it's from burger king
whether it's from throwing rocks or
whether it's from selling [ __ ]
surely she's going to take care of her
man you know what i mean you know what i
mean if she loves him
now they also have another theory that
brings us further up
and this was a theory that was developed
by older pimps and [ __ ]
well they said that slavery had a lot to
do with the original pimping
you understand they try to say that you
know you have to understand that
during the slave era
blacks were property of the white slave
owners
so the white slave owner could come [ __ ]
on
any of these women that he wanted to
because they were his property it wasn't
rape
even if she was married even if she had
a family on the plantation
he could [ __ ] on which one he won that's
why we got so many mixed breeds
today that's why we got so many
light-skinned people and mulattos as
they call it
today okay but now the theory goes that
once they freed the slaves these white
men still wanted to have sex
with these women but at the same time
now they're not your property anymore
now you have to have permission
to have sex with them so now you got
these same women who do have husbands
and boyfriends and stuff like that even
though it was
reconstruction era you understand
you got these men and saying well baby
go ahead and have sex with him because
we broke
we don't have [ __ ] we got kids and [ __ ]
we don't have no money
when you do go [ __ ] with whitey as they
call him no offense but when they
do go [ __ ] with him this time go get
something bring something home
because he wants you he doesn't want me
he's not calling me to the to the big
house to come [ __ ] on him
he's calling you so therefore since he's
calling you he's already hooked on that
[ __ ] because he's been hooked on it for
years when he was taking it from you you
understand
now he can't take it legally anymore
even though they still were
they're not taking it legally anymore so
therefore now it's time to charge
and they say that at that time the only
[ __ ] that was really doing good
at that time was really big shot
gamblers [ __ ] that was gamblers
and pimps those are [ __ ] that
had big horses at that time they was
riding big horses and they had big hats
and
they was fly and they and they learned
how to deal with prostitutes
they made prostitutes and they learned
how to deal with them because once a
woman becomes a prostitute she
thinks different she looks at the world
different and therefore she behaves
different
anyone who thinks different behaves
different even you once you start
thinking a certain way you start acting
a certain way
so that's just life so once these women
became prostitutes they began to think
different and act different
and these men who were instructing them
on how to go out there and get money
learned how to deal with them now
there's a certain way you have to deal
with prostitutes
that game is what they're talking about
when they say the book
of game because but these dudes didn't
write this down
they passed it down to the next
generation to their sons their nephews
hey man this is how you deal with a
prostitute
blah blah blah blah blah but now there's
the next generation who added to it and
they made it better and then you got the
next generation because you're talking
about the end of slavery so you're
talking about 1863 1868
blah blah blah next generation we're
talking about 1900
next generation we talk about 1930. now
1920 1930
here you got iceberg swim pimping up a
storm
you know iceberg slim was born in 1918
right by the time they had i think what
it world war one world war ii something
like that
he was pimping great but pimping i'm
talking about street pimping
no cell phones no none of that no hey
baby no
uh uh uh uh back page no none of that
[ __ ] go get it come on back with it
that's all i can do is send you out
there and trust you to come back with it
because i'm your man and with that money
i'm finna take care of you and bam
they passed that down and they passed it
down again
and they pass it down and now we're here
in this generation
but technology and all kind of [ __ ] has
also [ __ ] the game up
because you got a lot of different
theories and views you got gorillas
which there has always been
guerrilla pimps there's always been them
even though they don't really get
respect
from our circle from from real pimps
they don't really get respect
you understand what i mean but uh you
got all these different type of views so
[ __ ] is watered down
you know what i mean and [ __ ] is [ __ ] is
changed but there are still
real stumped down genuine 1000 percent
pimps and hoes out here in this
community
is uh is playing a trick for his watch
or is
his wallet or stuff like that part of
the game as well it's part of the game
but now
it's the question is is it condonable
who condones it you understand what i'm
saying
some dudes do that you understand what i
mean some dudes do that
uh like pimpsy told you you know what i
mean
if i got i'm not gonna encourage a woman
to do that but if a woman comes along
that has already
learned that that specialty and she's
doing it then i'm not going to
necessarily stop her
but at the same time yeah i would love
for a woman to come with a new rolex
watch or
this that any other but at the same time
that's just dangerous and it's not only
dangerous for her
it's dangerous for the community because
here it is
my girls let's just say hypothetically
my girl gets a trick
and she robs him for his watch and his
gold and his jury because he's drunk
coming from a party whatever
whatever he passes out he wakes up
everything's gone
now when he goes back on that boulevard
he's looking for her
okay she may not even be able to finish
work that night
which she might not have to because she
may have hit a big leg but now
it wouldn't even be safe for her to stay
out there because he's probably
somewhere driving around looking for her
but here's where it becomes dangerous
for not only her but it becomes
dangerous for the other females that's
out there the other [ __ ] is just on the
blade my pot this [ __ ] is this out
because he's mad so he don't give a [ __ ]
who he takes it out on
this [ __ ] just robbed me she took all
my money all my [ __ ]
she took advantage of me he's feeling
like a trick now and he's feeling like a
victim
right so now if he can't find my [ __ ]
who robbed him
he takes the next [ __ ] and does
something to her who knows how
horrendous that might be he might hurt
her he might robber he might rape her he
might stab her
anything and this you might be my best
friend and this is your girls and since
he couldn't find my girl he pulled up on
your girl who has no clue
that this [ __ ] has just happened to him
she's just trying to make a buck
and here it is she jumps in the car with
this dude and he goes through all the
regular [ __ ] oh yeah baby get in how
much yeah
oh we're going to go to my room unless
you know he takes her to a room and now
he hurts her
so that [ __ ] can bring [ __ ] to the
game you know what i mean that's
[ __ ] that i don't want to see that
happen to my female and i don't want to
see it i don't want to see it happen to
no female first of all but i damn sure
don't want to see it happen to mine and
i damn sure don't want to see it happen
to none of my close partners
females out there you understand what
i'm saying so it's like
it's an iffy thing is that really what
you want to do
you know what i mean and then what
happens when they get to calling the
police because now
here it is all these girls out here have
naked on figaro and all these other
streets
right and the police just riding by they
see these girls they know what these
girls is doing
but they're not stopping them
necessarily you know what i mean
but now if they're looking for a robbery
suspect
now they're pulling [ __ ] over now
they you see what i'm saying so now you
made this [ __ ] hot now you made the
blade hot
so i don't know if that's really
condonable i don't really push that
do you uh do you believe in true love or
is there always money and security
factored in do i believe in true love or
is there always
money and security factored in explain
that a little more so i can answer it
better like
a girl hooks up with a guy
just purely for his personality and and
how she feels when she's with him
or is the fact that he can provide
something for her or vice versa
she can provide something for him or
she's going to trade sex for money
basically
is there always a trade off of sex for
money in every relationship
or sometimes it's just pure love and
there's nothing else i think women learn
as little girls that
they're valuable to a degree they know
that
right not saying they're valuable to
agree to a degree i'm saying they learn
it to a degree
right pimp's helped them really
understand it but
since women were 11 and 12 men have been
approaching them sexually older men all
kind of
all kind of perverted [ __ ] comes out
from women i mean from men that only
women get to experience that men don't
ever see
right so they learn that they can get
something
out of men whether it's a ride whether
it's some candy whether it's
money whether it's whatever they learn
that right
so they learn that once they put their
self around
certain men you know men will kind of
cater to them and shower them with
certain [ __ ]
and their mothers teach them this and
they aunties and they teach it and they
run it down to them and [ __ ] like that
at the same time women are emotional
creatures and they do feel and they are
attracted to certain
men they're attracted to certain looks
things like that everybody has their
preference
so i believe that you don't necessarily
have to have money or anything because
you look what we at man we downtown
los angeles right you see whole couples
intense
you see whole couples in boxes living
down here
but they thugging it out he ain't got
[ __ ] he ain't offering her [ __ ] he ain't
selling drugs he ain't pimping he ain't
[ __ ] but she's with him so it's
something about him that she digs that
she [ __ ] with is something that you can
call it true love you can call it
something
but she [ __ ] with him i believe that
the aspect or the addition of money
and benefits and things that can that
can draw a woman
closer but i've had money and i've tried
to talk to some broke [ __ ]
and they wasn't giving me no play
because they had a man and they both was
broke
both of them was bums and my money
didn't impress the [ __ ] enough to come
with me
you understand what i'm saying so i
don't necessarily i don't necessarily
know
if that's a guaranteed factor i believe
that is a factor in some aspects of life
and i do
believe in true love you know what i
mean and i'm talking about
universal love you understand what i'm
saying i'm talking about universal love
i'm talking about you know
i could love you you can love me as men
as i'm talking about as a friend i'm
sure there's a friend a male
friend that if you found out he had a
plane crash and died you would be hurt
you'd be devastated
you understand what i'm saying so love
is universal
you know what i mean and and and love is
for everybody
you know what i mean love is for pimps
love is for hoes
love is for men women animals love is
for everybody you understand what i mean
and i believe that
that's going to happen regardless of
whether you have
money or you know things like that i
don't think that's necessarily a a
element that has to be there
how many how many girls do you have in
your stable typically well right now man
i'm retired you know what i'm saying
right now i'm retired you know what i
mean i'm just
right now i'm just mentoring to the
youth i'm talking to younger dudes
that's out there trying to get it i'm
still out in the streets you still see
when you were active oh when i was
active i think the most girls i had was
about four
you know what i mean i have four girls
and that's that in itself is a headache
you know what i mean i just was just
reading something else i think it was on
instagram somebody put
uh all these pimps out here want to be
deep
until they got four girls
until they're being pulled eight
different ways by four different girls
you know what i mean that shit's a
headache i mean i've been in a situation
where all the girls came from work i got
them all in my car
and they're all hungry they all stink
because they've been working
they all want to shower one is like i
get me home so i can shower
another one's like daddy i'm hungry this
one's hungry that's hungry they all want
to eat
but they only eat different [ __ ] she
wants taco bell she wants kentucky fried
chicken she wants burger king and this
one is too [ __ ] bougie to eat fast
food
you want to say i don't eat fast food i
need some more real food and that
adores she's a vegetarian or some bushes
so now what am i doing am i
door dashing this [ __ ] home or what the
[ __ ] am i gotta drive to taco bell and
drive here
but i'm gonna make sure they got what
they want because these [ __ ] just
came in the house with
this [ __ ] got 800 this [ __ ] got 1200
this [ __ ] got niner i mean god damn i'm
not gonna feed the [ __ ]
and i'm not gonna make them eat what the
[ __ ] they want to eat you know i mean
i'm going to make them eat what i want
them to need
you know i'm going to get you what you
[ __ ] you want to eat you know what i
mean but that [ __ ] becomes a headache at
the same time you know what i mean
you have sex with your girls oh most
definitely once again i gotta speak on
what
kenny red told you when you answered
that question a prostitute is like your
wife
if i'm not [ __ ] my my whole who else
am i [ __ ] if i don't if i'm sitting
here claiming
that i don't [ __ ] with square [ __ ]
because you only
this is how we look at it the world
consists of pimps holes and squares
that's it now you're going to hear gang
members and you're going to hear drug
dealers and them
also refer to themselves as non-squares
and when we're in their presence we'll
allow them to have that
but between pimps and hoes we feel like
the world just consists of pimps
hoes and squares so if it ain't pimping
and horn is square so now i'm saying to
you
if i'm not if i'm claiming that i don't
[ __ ] with square [ __ ]
then who's left i'm not [ __ ] no pimps
so it's only pencils and squares i'm not
[ __ ] squares and i'm not [ __ ]
pimps so who else i'm a [ __ ] who hasn't
have a baby block but my husband
that's the only this is my family this
is my woman and these these are my women
you know what i mean but like shantae
said and i gotta i gotta speak on him
with another one of my great mentors
like he said
your dick belongs in your household
though
don't hide your [ __ ] down on the blade
selling [ __ ] don't hide your [ __ ]
on back page or wherever going doing
dates
and while she's out doing dates you
[ __ ] the [ __ ] downstairs that ain't
gave you a nickel and yang money
that's just wrong you're just
disrespecting her homie as a pimp you
have the right to do that you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want to but
i consider that and we consider that
real consider that [ __ ] miss pimping
what are you doing you you are
disrespecting her holding in a way
because here's a [ __ ] that's dedicated
to you enough to go out here and get you
some money
and she got a [ __ ] you can [ __ ] on her
you know what i'm saying but
but yet you [ __ ] the laundry lady
downstairs that's got a whole husband
that's giving her money
to a whole nother [ __ ] when this
[ __ ] is out here taking penitentiary
chances for you
so like he said your dick belongs in
your household
you know what i mean and i damn so try
to keep mine in my house though
you know a lot of a lot of outsiders a
lot of squares will
say that you guys are sex traffickers
you know what i think that's just a part
of this new propaganda that they got
going on you know obama let a lot of the
drug dealers out of jail federal and
state
you know what i mean freed up a lot of
space a lot of people been complaining
about overpopulation of the jails and
y'all not building enough schools y'all
building too many jails so they start
letting a lot of the drug you know they
got light on the drug offenses
you are a white guy but at the same time
i know you understand racial politics in
this country
and slavery has never really ended it
was
you know it was uh it was criminalized
but it never really ended they always
felt figured out a way
to still enslave black men even after
slavery was over you had the
sharecropping era you know what i mean
which still was a form of slavery and
you go on and on and on
now what we're doing is we're using uh
incarceration as a form of slavery
because blacks and latinos
make up the majority of the prisons in
the united states
right so now that you let all these drug
dealers and [ __ ] out you got all this
space
well who are the majority of pimps black
men
yeah you might get a mexican pimp here
one of the great pimps that i
that i know of another person that i
respect is white folks who's a white boy
that
pimps astoundingly right but at the same
time they're the exceptions the majority
of pimps are
black so what better way is to
criminalize that more than it already
has been
by taking something that was once called
pimping and pandering that carried two
three
six years and turned it into something
called human trafficking
where now it's carrying 12 16 and 20
years
the minimum is 12. but what better way
to get
okay well i got all these black men out
here pimping what better way to get them
in jail
what better way to put them into oh
you're pimping you're going to jail we
get us a human trafficking bureau
and we uh we get a whole set now we're
taking that a step up from vice which
they've always had a vice department but
now we got a human trafficking bureau
that
specializes specifically on pimps and
hoes and prostitution
now we filling up the jails like i said
when i first went to jail for pimping
there were no pimps in jail i was
probably like the only one
a older pimp told me and he was in there
for something else but he ended up
telling me he said
hey man i know young pimping you know
you on fire for the pimping
he said but you need to stop telling
these [ __ ] you some pimping man
you know what i'm saying i want
everybody to know me i'm a pimp no i'm a
pimp
you feel me but at the same time [ __ ]
ain't
[ __ ] like you say pimping is looked
down on but
especially by squares squares are
intimidated by pimps because they feel
like we got some kind of power over
women that they don't have they they get
insecure it makes them insecure
just like hoes imitate intimidate square
[ __ ]
because they feel like oh this [ __ ]
ain't going to never have sex with my
man this but i don't want that [ __ ]
around my man i don't
you know it's a lot of intimidation
factors there right so now when you go
to jail you got all these tough ass
[ __ ] in there telling you a pimp
ain't that a [ __ ] [ __ ] i got sisters
[ __ ] i never pimped me i got a i got a
mama
i got daughters you know what i'm saying
what type of [ __ ] is that so my father
had to tell me like pimping these [ __ ]
ain't liking you bro
you know what i'm saying because you
went around the tongue all this pimp
[ __ ] but you need to leave that alone
then they want to flip it about what a
pimple do oh i heard a pimple sell his
own ass if you don't have you know all
this ridiculous [ __ ] why am i selling my
ass when i got a bishop to sell hers
that's ridiculous you know what i mean
but they got a lot of negative
aspects that they like to uh associate
with this game but you gotta understand
you had rapists child molesters and
pimps all like them here in the same
category i'm talking about like
1920s 1930s so it was horrendous to be a
pimp it was it was it was gross to be a
pimp
but now in our age you got the rappers
and you got 50 cent making his song pen
but you got snoop dogg commercializing
pimping and
you got sugar free and you got bishop
and all these [ __ ] so now it's
fashionable to be pimpers
you know what i mean now it's looked on
as a good thing so that's why you got so
many
knuckleheads getting in the game that
don't know what the [ __ ] they doing they
got a girlfriend and they like oh well
i'll just watch the video i'm gonna be a
pimp baby all you gotta do is stand
right here on eighty third and finger
roll
you understand and he don't know the
first thing about taking care of a woman
because that's what this is about this
is about upgrading
uplifting and loving and taking care of
a woman
who knows the value of her
body and knows the value of herself
because i hear women all the time squid
[ __ ] say well i would never [ __ ] for
money
i value my [ __ ] more than that my [ __ ]
is worth more than that
i said well do you value your house she
said yeah
i said do you value your car i said yeah
i said would you give it to me for free
she said hell no i wouldn't well why
would you give me your [ __ ] for free if
you claim you value that
you understand what i'm saying so it
makes no sense
you see so our job is to instruct her
and teach her how valuable she really is
to teach her the fact that baby you can
walk down the street baby you should
never be broke because [ __ ] said when
cotton and cornwall
you understand what i'm saying there's
no reason in in in
in the world that a female should be
hungry
that a female should be broke because
[ __ ]
sells and the thing is you're gonna [ __ ]
anyway
you're gonna [ __ ] somebody you're gonna
[ __ ] somebody and the cool thing about
it is you'll go to a motel you'll meet
some guy that you think is cute because
he likes skin green eyes long hair
whatever the [ __ ] it is
you'll meet him you'll go to the room
you'll suck his dick you let him [ __ ]
you
all night off a goddamn rhino pill right
you'll wake up in the morning
give him some more head and when the man
come knocking at the door for the rent
money at 11 o'clock
you or him ain't got no [ __ ]
rent money now y'all got all your bags
walking down the street
but you broke but you've been well
[ __ ] you've been thoroughly [ __ ]
you may have busted a nut you know what
i mean if he knew what he was doing
you understand what i'm saying but [ __ ]
you still broke
so why not do all that and still get
paid so you can at least pay the rent
[ __ ] you didn't commit four or five sex
acts you know how much money you're
gonna got for all them sex acts
you committed all these goddamn sex acts
[ __ ] and you can't pay the rent
yeah it takes a pimp to hip a [ __ ] to
that to make her
understand that like that's ridiculous
to do something so how much do you
really value yourself when you gave it
away for free
being that you wouldn't give your house
and your car away for free because you
see value in that
but you get your [ __ ] away for free do
you really value it
you understand what i'm saying so that's
how i feel about that those was
my aspect one last question uh what's
the most important lesson you've learned
man i've learned so many goddamn lessons
man but one of the
main lessons i've learned is uh
communicate communicate with everybody
though
you understand what i'm saying
communication communication is the rule
of the nation that's what they say
and you have to communicate with that
female and you have to understand see
what's great about this
is that when a person watches this video
right now it's going to be a bunch of
[ __ ] they're not going to retain
all the [ __ ] that i said but the great
thing about it is they can rewind it
and they can watch it again and they can
watch it again so that they get more and
more the information
that i am communicating right but when
i'm talking to my woman
and i'm sending her to the street or i'm
sending her on a date and i'm saying
baby look make sure you do this right
make sure you do that right
for your safety for us because i want
you to come back to me that's the main
goal i need you to get back so i'm
trying to communicate this to you but
i'm telling you a whole bunch of [ __ ]
but guarantee she's probably only
retaining about
maybe hopefully 50 60 of what you just
told her and she can't go back and
rewind it unless you're gonna tape
yourself
talking to her right so you have to
communicate with that female and
communicate with her and communicate
with her sometimes over and over because
i know girls say to me
okay daddy i know okay i've heard it
i've heard it
right but i have to teach myself
to communicate more and more and more so
that you get it so that you
understand it so that you're safe out
there so that you can go get the money
so that you can come back to me safely
so when communication is right the
nation is right
you understand what i'm saying and
that's what i believe man you know what
i'm saying peanut on my church
that was great thank you brother i
appreciate it very interesting
you